all right you have $1,300 to spend on an
Android slab phone in
2024 why would you get any other
phone no seriously why would you get any
other phone this s24 Ultra has taken the
best things from every other Ultra
highend phone and stuff them into one
place so anything that you could
possibly value it has pushed to the Max
and there's just multiple cherries on
top just sprinkled all over the place
this phone sets the tone for 2024
[Music]
so the formula for Samsung's Ultra
phones has evolved a little bit over the
years at first it was just the most
numbers the biggest megapixel count the
most zoom and all that then it added the
S Pen and got a little more refined and
it replac the note now it's just
everything it's just everything in one
place it's all the best Hardware all the
best software I can think of all in one
phone so on the outside like I said in
my early Impressions this phone looks
almost the same as last year's phone but
if you think this phone is almost the
same as last year's phone turns out
you're missing a lot so the more you use
this phone the more you look for
weaknesses the more impressive it gets
so maybe what you're a you're a screen
snob right you like to pixel peep maybe
you were thinking about getting one of
the ultra high-end Oppo or xiaomi phones
just for an amazing screen all right
well look no further literally one of
the best screens in any phone s24 Ultra
has dropped in a class leading 6.8 in
Quad HD AMOLED display and it is awesome
these Ultra phones have had you know 120
HZ ltpo for a while and they've been
this really sharp Quad HD for a while
now too but now on top of that two new
things one is it's completely flat and
two is it's much brighter so there's
been this whole new batch of like 2,500
plus knit phones in the past couple
months that I've seen this I think is
the best looking one that I've seen so
far so now it's up to a Max 2,600 nits
which is awesome Outdoors or anywhere
but it also gets extremely dim at night
too without any of the weird banding
I've seen in some other phones and they
flattened the display completely and
brought the display right up to the very
Corners with some of the thinnest bezels
we've seen all the way around plus
there's also this new anti-reflective
coating on this gorilla glass armor that
makes a noticeable difference with
certain light hitting it at off axis
angles and then there is a crazy fast
ultrasonic fingerprint reader underneath
to top it all off and you know maybe I
wish the touch Target was a little bit
bigger but that's about it honestly if
you're a screen snob it doesn't really
get better than this one right here this
is the phone you should get okay so what
if your primary concern is battery life
well you could always get the Energizer
phone that we saw at CES at one time but
as far as reasonably sized Flagship slab
phones go it doesn't get much better
than this again they're keeping a 5,000
mAh battery in one of the best
performing battery phones from the past
few years despite making it thinner and
keeping the S Pen so you might as well
get this one still got 45 watt wired
charging you still have 25 wat wireless
charging and just battery LifeWise I was
able to have long days with no problems
with six hours plus a screen on time I
was able to baby it into getting two
full days that's at 1440p at 120 htz and
with high brightness use so yeah why why
get anything else so okay what if then
it's just performance is the main thing
that you care about
okay so we're seeing all these phones
with a Snapdragon 8 gen 3 starting to
come out and they're looking really good
great high-end performance there's
efficiency gains all over the place plus
this phone pairs it with 12 gigs of RAM
and it is a multitasking champ and if
it's a stylus you're into I already know
you weren't really considering any other
phone the Spen is basically the only
high-end stylus still going in slab
smartphones it's really good for not
taking drawing highlighting all that
stuff but if you're like me and you
hardly ever use that there's still the
gaming per performance and the everyday
performance there's the newly added Ray
tracing plus a 90% larger Vapor chamber
to cool the phone for much longer stuff
turns out it's an A+ now you could
always get a gaming phone and squeeze 5
to 10% more frames out of a Snapdragon 8
gen 3 with some huge badass cooling
setup and that's great but then you also
have to accept all of the sacrifices
that come with said gaming phone over
this and do you really want those extra
frames that
bad depends on who you ask okay cameras
there's a lot of other phones out there
that you could buy if your 1,300 bucks
specifically has to go to the best
cameras you know the pixel just won the
blind camera test Sony has the best
manual mode like there's other great
camera systems but here's a way to
simplify it I think in evaluating
smartphone cameras there's basically two
ways to review them there's the utility
the actual technical evaluation and the
Aesthetics the art of it the
subjectivity part and I think
utilitywise like on paper specs wise
this this camera's got it all like
you've seen this camera array before
there's four cameras on the back of this
phone turns out they're basically the
same cameras as last year's s23 Ultra
except for one so there's a primary
camera an ultrawide and a pair of two
different telephoto cameras the primary
camera is still the ridiculous 200
megapixel sensor with all the same pros
and cons it's consistent and versatile
across the board it has great dynamic
range it's a quick shooter with quick
autofocus and it's also always binning
down to 12 megapixels and you should
almost never switch it to the 200
megapixel mode unless you have
incredible lighting it has an ultra wide
with a bit of distortion near the edges
but it's actually meaningfully wider
than the primary camera so it's really
fun to shoot with even though the
automatic macro mode from it looks like
trash and you should just turn it off
anytime it turns your pictures from this
to this Pro tip and then it has a medium
range 3x telephoto camera that kicks in
smooth smoothly and matches the colors
and exposure from the main camera really
well and so the one new thing in
Hardware this year is they've gone from
a 10 megapixel 10x camera to a 50
megapixel 5x camera so technically
shorter optical zoom range but I would
say with the extra resolution it is
actually more powerful it means all the
photos in the gap between 5x and 10x
look sharper than last year and then you
can literally put the 10x photos side by
side from the s23 ultra and the s24
ultra and the new 5x cropped in actually
looks better plus you can still Zoom all
the way in and shoot at 100x if you
still want to take Ultra stable pictures
of Far Away objects like the moon but
basically what I'm saying is utilitywise
this camera system checks every single
box it has everything so from there you
get into the more subjective athetic
differences which you could always lean
one way or the other I think I mean
looking at the these photos they're
still very much Samsung's slightly extra
process looking a little bit extra
contrasty a little bit higher exposure a
little brighter colors that still
happens with these photos so you could
still convince yourself to lean pixel or
even iPhone but if you just want to be
able to check every single box why look
anywhere else honestly the changes that
you notice more aside from the actual
camera quality are just like features
using it like the s24 ultra shoots
everything HDR by default now it's
actually in Google's new Ultra HDR
format so when you have you know
specular highlights or big dynamic range
differences in a photo it will
Tastefully crank up that stuff for a
more dramatic looking picture on the
phone screen similar to what pixel and
iPhone already do and this passes
through all the way from capturing the
photo to viewing it in the gallery and
then one more step to actually
publishing it on social media so Samsung
has worked with Instagram and Snapchat
for Native quality photo and video
uploading pipelines because at the end
of the day once you take the photo what
are you 99% of the time planning to do
with it share it and I think this is
this is important for a lot of people
this is one of the reasons I have
carried an iPhone for years is one of
the things you can always count on is
the photos and videos in third-party
apps are going to look just as good as
if they were captured in the main camera
and now you can actually say that that
is true now about photos and videos from
this phone at least in Instagram and
Snapchat all right maybe you're a
software person maybe the top of your
list when buying a new smartphone is you
want the smartest smartphone it's got to
have all the software and AI features
and honestly it should have a nice long
road map ahead of it of ontime software
updates sounds like I'm describing a
pixel but turns out this phone now has a
ton a ton of helpful AI features built
in that are actually good they make a
meaningful difference to Everyday Use
now the funny part about a lot of this
is a lot of these features are made in
partnership with Google as you'll see
and I can't help but keep thinking like
it feels like Samsung needs Google to
have all of these features in their
phone to compete especially against the
iPhone but then Google Now their own
phones are a little bit less competitive
but it's probably worth a trade-off
because now technically they're helping
to compete against the iPhone it's this
weird like thing where they need each
other I I think it's fascinating and
probably worth its own separate video
maybe let me know with a comment or by
sub subcribing if you'd be down to see
that but that's all the background all
this so we were just talking about
photos a second ago the second you're
done taking a photo and opening it up in
Samsung's Gallery app there's a ton of
useful AI driven stuff that you can do
with it and it's kind of all based on
what sort of scene it autod detects that
you've taken so lots of photos just end
up with a remaster button where you
click it and then it can add some
contrast and brighten things up a little
bit as needed and give you a solid
before and after but if your photo has
some glass or a window it'll show you an
erase Reflections button and then you
can literally go in and circle the
reflections you want to get rid of and
it'll generative fill what should
actually be in the glass and it works
pretty well now with this photo I didn't
take it in portrait mode but it's
recognized that there's a subject and so
it'll offer to add background blur and
even without a bunch of extra depth
information it analyzes the subject and
it lets me add a little bit or a lot of
background blur with a pretty damn good
cutout if you ask me to just create a
portrait mode shot out of thin air but
if you ever really really want to go
crazy there's a whole separate
magic editor that feels exactly like
what we just got with the pixel minus
any restrictions it's never told me it
can't do something so you open any photo
hit that edit button and then there's
this little blue green button with the
Stars that's Samsung's new magic editor
and once you're here you can just go
nuts you can move the subject around a
photo and have a generative fill in the
background or you can have it remove
things entirely from the foreground or
the background of a photo like Photo
bombers or just unnecessary random
objects I actually found this super
useful but probably actually my favorite
one underrated you know how normally
when you need to tilt a photo like fix
the Horizon you end up cropping in and
losing some of the outside of the photo
you can still do that but with this
magic editor you can open it up and tilt
The Horizon to whatever angle you want
and instead of cropping it will
literally generative fill in the
outsides of the photo which works very
well because usually the outside of the
photo is the least important part of the
photo you can get away with generative
fill and by the way literally all the
stuff works with photos you download to
the phone too not just photos you've
taken on the camera but photos you just
get wherever just like the pixel now I
also find it hilarious that if you use
the magic Editor to alter a photo on
this phone it'll add a little Watermark
to the bottom corner with this little
stars so that you know that this photo
was AI manipulated which is good that's
a good responsible thing to do
especially if you're going to upload
this to social media but then you can
also immediately erase that watermark
with a built-in object removal tool in
Samsung's photo editor app there's a
nice little section in the settings
where Samsung's tucked all of the AI
features of this phone it's called
advanced intelligence instead of
artificial intelligence still AI though
uh that's where you get stuff like the
live phone call translation feature or
the new voice recorder app getting much
improved speaker labels and summaries
and transcriptions the Samsung browser
will now do uh summaries of web pages
this might all sound very familiar but
the best new one in my opinion is circle
to search now Google lens has been
around for a long time in my opinion one
of Google's most underrated products so
people might have already known that you
could basically do this already it would
take several steps Circle to search just
makes it one step it it's much faster
it's pretty awesome you literally just
hold down on the home button or the
gesture bar at the bottom and then
Circle or tap whatever on your screen
that you want to Google search and it
just immediately Googles over the top of
whatever you were doing without leaving
that app and it's so useful just even
during the week I've been using this
phone I've searched pictures parts of
pictures before it almost always works
just like uploading it to Google Lens
I've searched objects right in front of
me through the camera viewfinder I've
searched random landmarks you can also
search text and you can even append text
to your search and I was just constantly
impressed by how fast it is and it
basically works as expected every single
time the one fidgety part is sometimes
selecting text gets a little weird using
the Spen can solve that a little bit to
just get a more precise selection but
yeah once you do it it's much faster
than if you're going to use Google Lens
having to like take a screenshot and
then upload it through lens and then
maybe have to crop it and the whole
thing this is just fast now real ogs
will know that there used to be a
feature on pixels called now on tap it
was like the same exact thing hold the
home button and it would just Google
whatever was on your screen and help you
out but that was everything on your
screen and they kind of ended up
wrapping that into Google Assistant this
is just so much faster and more
selective also pixels are going to get
this feature very soon as well but then
bonus points if you really love software
Samsung is now promising seven years of
security updates and seven generations
of major software updates on this phone
on this s24 lineup I assume seven
generations of software updates is
basically seven years that means this
phone will be up to date in
2031 l in that so we know the common
wisdom was that if you wanted four five
six plus years of software updates or if
you want every single little software
and AI feature you basically had to go
iPhone or pixel but now that this phone
also has that why get anything else but
speaking of the iPhone they're going at
them too now I know I said in the
beginning of this video $1,300 slab
Android phone so I know the iPhone 15
Pro Max was never really on the table
but if we're being honest Samsung has
never been shy about competing directly
against the iPhone so why not take some
of the best stuff stuff from there too
they weren't being subtle about it so
they've got this shiny brand new
titanium color with titanium rails on
the s24 ultra just like the iPhone they
have flattened the screen and the sides
and made box your Corners all the way
through the lineup just like the iPhone
they have moved to a Max 5x telephoto
lens like I talked about earlier also
just like the iPhone they also have this
new always on display that doesn't just
show the time but shows your whole
wallpaper now kind of like it's half
awake just like the iPhone thankfully
you can also turn that off and save some
battery just like the iPhone you can
also now long press to select an object
in a photo that automatically cuts it
out and makes it a sticker you can use
in other apps just like the iPhone and
there's even these new lock screen
widgets now that look exactly like the
iPhones like like copy my homework but
don't even worry if they know you copied
it these two are going to keep copying
each other till the end of time none of
this is a surprise it's just at the end
of the day we are technically winning
because they're making each other a
little bit better bit by bit but at the
end of the day s24 Ultra ra I really do
feel like feels it feels like Peak slab
phone there's also a whole bunch of
stuff I didn't even really mention with
this phone the haptics are really nice I
didn't even get to that there's AI
generated wallpapers a whole section for
them if you're into that and it's nice
that the AI stuff is mostly kind of
tucked away in ways where you don't ever
have to use it if you don't want to but
if you notice it and it's helpful to you
bam turn it on could be your favorite
feature really the only things that I
miss from the pixel specifically are
call screening and now playing so really
the best argument not to buy this $1,300
phone is the fact that it's a $1,300
phone and the truth is you can get 98%
of the phone for much less money you can
see it in Samsung's own lineup Samsung's
own s24 plus has a 4,900 mAh battery
instead of 5,000 it has a 6.7 in display
instead of 6.8 and it drops the Spen and
one of the telephoto cameras for
$300 off and and you know you can get uh
the regular s24 again for much less
money with almost as much phone so you
don't have to spend 1,300 bucks on a
phone but if you are going to and you
put the word Ultra in the name and you
stuff as much stuff in one phone as you
possibly can this is the one that you
should get this has all the things it's
reliable it's fast it does everything it
checks all the
boxes this phone's great kind of feels
like an ad when I just say all these
positive things about the phone but it's
not until right now this video is
sponsored by Ridge the ridge wallet is
Iconic at this point it's a minimalist
modern wallet it's like the opposite of
those old school wallets it's got the
patented dual track design that expands
to hold one to 12 cards while being as
Slim as possible and at this point
there's like 30 plus different colors
and styles including carbon fiber burnt
titanium and forged Ember this one is
the forged Ember so it's got these
little red flexs in it which look cool
you can also get accessories for it so
if you want to carry cash you might want
the money clip or this one has the cash
strap or if you want the air tag holder
you can get one that holds an air tag to
it so you never lose your wallet and on
top of all that if you get one and you
don't like it you can return it within
99 days no questions asked so if you
want to grab one you can get 10% off
using Code MKBHD or go to ridge.com
MKBHD tell them I sent you either way
that's been it for the
s24 ultra thanks for watching catch you
guys in the next one
peace